thank you
[Music]
well hello dear friends we're glad that
you decided to join our program I'd like
to know which is a question and answer
program where you send us your questions
online and we do the research and do
everything possible to find an answer to
your question I'd like to give you the
address where you can send us your
questions you'll see it on the screen TV
at some tv.org once again TV at some
tv.org we would be delighted to receive
your questions
please be patient because we receive
lots of questions and we try to be
exhaustive in our answers and so it
might take a while to get to your
questions but eventually we will I have
with me David Salazar who is in charge
of some TV Latino as well as many other
responsibilities he's a contractor he's
been a lot of help to the ministry not
only in the area of theology but also in
the area of Contracting with good
Council and we're very glad that you're
here Pastor Salazar thank you Pastor
Boris a blessing to be able to share
this time with you and answer these
questions that are really important
sometimes to to like you said do the
research and answer them according to
the Bible is for prophecy amen would you
have a word of prayer for us absolutely
Pastor let's let's have a prayer
heavenly father as we come to you this
moment to study your word and to share
from your word we simply ask that he
will send the Holy Spirit to teachers
and lead us into all truth to be able to
give us the right answers not that we
may portray our own knowledge but that
your knowledge your wisdom your word may
speak through
through our our lips we pray that you
will bless us and guide us we as all
these in Jesus name amen amen okay we
have a very interesting questions to
start out with yes
and this question comes from Wilson
um it arrived a couple of months ago you
know we're behind because we have so
many questions
but the question is this what is the
identity of the eighth
in Revelation 17 verse 11. so maybe we
should read the verse and then offer an
interpretation absolutely let me read
there in chapter 17 of Revelation verse
11. it says there and the Beast that was
and is not even he is the eighth and
he's of the seven and goeth into
perdition
okay so the question is what is the
identity of the eighth in Revelation 17
verse 11. the first thing that I'd like
to mention is that this Beast does not
have eight heads
that's correct very clearly the Beast
has seven heads it's repeated in verse
three verse 7 verse 9 verse 10 and verse
11. there is no such thing as eight
heads exactly it doesn't appear just an
eighth hit somewhere right yeah that
that the seventh head counts as an
eighth in other words the number eight
is related to the seventh head correct
and um you know there's this book that I
would like to recommend uh I have an old
Edition that has a picture of a harlot
sitting on a leopard-like beast with a
cup of wine in her hand but I'd like to
show it anyway it's available these days
uh under the title The Woman and the
Beast in Revelation and there's an
entire chapter here on the importance of
the number eight in the Bible because
numbers in the Bible are very important
just like names right and basically the
chapter shows that the number eight is
the number of the Resurrection action in
The Bible and so the seventh head in
some way must have resurrected from a
wound that it received before right and
so uh the eighth head must be a power
that ruled for a while received a deadly
wound and then denoted by the number
eight resurrects from uh its lethargy if
you please absolutely now you know there
is this Concepts sometimes Pastor that
gets people confused you know and and
what this brother is sharing with us it
sort of perhaps is what goes on in the
mind of many of our listeners that have
this question what really does that
eighth head mean is it really or or as
mentioned right now part of the seven
it's a really uh Power like the heads
symbolize or it's maybe a particular
person you know there's these ideas
sometimes that I've heard it and you've
heard it too that uh maybe these are
things that are related to the Beast a
revelation
there may be the popes or things of that
nature but we can clearly show and I
think that you have a very strong
argument as we just mentioned that the
eighth so-called is actually the seventh
and it's really the aspect of
resurrection of that seventh head or
beast yeah another evidence that the
seventh head resurrects after receiving
a wound
is where this Beast rises from verse 8
this Beast rises from the bottomless pit
or from the abyss correct which the New
Testament identifies as the place where
Jesus went when he died and we know that
Jesus did not go to some pit deep down
under the Earth right you know it simply
means the grave the grave yeah and so
why does this Beast rise from the grave
well it must be that it received a
deadly wound at some point
um you know in Revelation chapter 12 you
have a dragon that is seen in heaven
because it's a description of a Heavenly
controversy in Revelation chapter 13 you
have a beast that rises from the sea
well the reason why it rises from the
sea is because it rises where there's
multitudes tongues and peoples right
Revelation 13 you have a a beast that
rises from the earth because it's a very
densely not a densely populated area
correct and then in Revelation 17 you
have this Beast that rises from the
abyss so wherever these beasts are seen
is important in the interpretation of
the particular passage under study
absolutely now it's interesting to know
as we you know as he's asking for
identity of that eighth head or which is
actually the seventh it's interesting to
know or for him to understand or for us
to share with him that we've actually
placed the order of these kingdoms or
these heads in the correct order and
from verse 10 it speaks there as John
was seen the vision of that woman
writing the Beast
it mentions that there are seven Kings
and it says there are five are Fallen
one is and the other one is not yet come
and when he cometh he must continue a
short space so it's telling us right now
that from the moment he's in the vision
the time he's in the vision he sees five
who had already fallen there's this six
that he's seen and that seventh that is
to come and you know as we see in verse
11 it's actually connected to the eighth
that is gonna return or come back to
life in other words that seven come back
to life we need to now place them
identify these all these seven so that
we can actually give the answer to our
friend who's asking what that entity is
so Pastor give us the explanation of
what those seven heads are or kings are
okay before I I mentioned that
um some people get hung up by the
wording seven Kings yes so they think
there's seven individuals yes but really
Kings and kingdoms are interchangeable
to the Bible in Daniel chapter Two uh
you know it says to Nebuchadnezzar you
are the head of gold but then it says
after you will arise another kingdom
yeah so King and kingdoms are
interchangeable right
um you know in Daniel chapter 7 you have
a little horn right that rises from the
head among the ten horns and you know
the bottom line is that in that chapter
Kings and kingdoms are interchangeable
right and furthermore it says that the
seven heads are seven mountains and in
the Bible mountains represent kingdoms
mountains do not represent the
individual Kings correct so the first
thing is we need to know that these are
Seven Kingdoms correct they are not
seven individuals like many people
believe now what are the seven uh heads
right on the basis of a study that I did
and by the way I'm going to go out and
limb if anybody's interested in the full
study that I did on this a phrase by
phrase word by word study of the chapter
um I'll be glad to send it to you it's
33 pages long it deals with many
different issues relating to Revelation
chapter 17 but on the basis of my study
I believe that the seven heads are
Babylon middle Persia Greece
Pagan Rome table room these are the
first five who are following right who
were who are Fallen according to the
text uh the sixth Kingdom I believe as
the United States of America
and the United States of America being
the sixth Kingdom gives its Kingdom to
the seventh head because the beast from
the earth which represents the United
States is instrumental in returning
power or giving resurrected resurrected
power to the papacy so the sixth head
would be the United States a kingdom
that gives its Kingdom to the seventh
head which is the papacy I can read a
statement here from Ellen White that
clearly identifies uh the United States
as a kingdom She Wrote This is in the
book uh devotional book Maranatha page
187 what is it that gives its Kingdom to
this power what is it that gives its
Kingdom to the papacy in other words
correct protestantism
and when you when you talk about
protestantism you're talking about the
United States as we see in what she
writes next protestantism a power which
while professing to have the temper and
spirit of a lamb it's Revelation 13 11.
and to be Allied to Heaven speaks with
the voice of a dragon that's the Beast
that rises from the earth it is moved by
a power from beneath and so clearly the
United States is the kingdom because it
says what is it that gives its Kingdom
to this power
so what happens the United States gives
its Kingdom or its ruling power to the
beasts that received the deadly wound
the Beast that received the deadly wound
resurrects
it denoted by the number eight and by
the fact that it's coming from the abyss
which is the realm of the dead so when
you put everything together it fits
perfectly it makes perfect sense I mean
and another aspect is that and I think
this is where perhaps or I can see where
the concept of the eighth comes in in
the sense that as the United States will
give its power its authority to the
seventh head that head
initially as he receives the power is
only uh uh part of the the experience of
the Catholic or the papacy in the system
as a religious entity but when it
becomes fully that entity of persecution
where he receives the authority from the
seven the sixth Beast which is the
United States then it's this is why it
becomes a resurrection if you will of
that
period of time when she was a full
persecuting power so that is why I think
that the expression the eighth is really
more in the sense of resurrecting that
existence as a persecuting power which
we know it will happen and it will
influence the world
to follow or receive mark of the beast
so it's what it is you know it really
like you said if fits really well
together these pieces and and what
something that you mentioned is
extremely important and that is that
these seven heads represent powers that
persecuted God's people okay including
the United States will be a persecutor
right now is not so so they're not just
Seven Kingdoms there are Seven Kingdoms
that persecuted God's people now some
people believe that the sixth head is
France right in the French Revolution
um but France did not persecute the
Saints of the most high France
persecuted the Beast and gave its deadly
wound and so I don't see uh France being
denoted by the sixth uh head uh that we
find here now some people also believe
that they that the seven heads are seven
individual poles yes that's where they
they get the idea that Kings means
individuals and the interpretation that
is given if I can maybe find this
uh the interpretation that is given is
that
and this Theory came up during the time
of the Pope John Paul II the idea is
that
um the five that are Fallen are Pious
the 11th
these are since 1929. and it makes you
wonder why do they start with 1929
anyway a Pious the 11th Pius the 12th
John the 23rd Pope Paul VI and John Paul
the first who ruled only about a month
those are the five that are fallen in
the days when when John Paul was the
pope correct so the six with G John Paul
and the other one that has not yet come
is Benedict who would last a very short
time and the eighth would be Francis the
first
so so it seems to fit
the only problem is that they're not
eight heads there are only seven heads
exactly so you can't say that Francis is
the eighth head now
if Francis should die
and another Pope elected this whole
Theory
will be totally destroyed right we have
to be very careful about
um
being Ultra specific
by taking what is happening out there
and plugging plugging it into the Bible
you know this sounds pretty logical in
the time of John Paul II but it doesn't
sound quite as logical these days I'd
like to read also a couple of statements
here from the spirit of Prophecy and
also from uh Uriah Smith not Uriah Smith
not Jay and Andrews correct about the
meaning of the seven heads of this
Scarlet Beast particularly the last
three
uh this is um Jane Andrews the three
messages in Revelation 14
and it's Pages uh 77 and 78 I have this
book in my library I think it might be
out of print but you probably can get it
on Amazon
this is what he wrote the seven heads
are seven forms of civil power
which ruled
successively one after the other
these seven heads belong alike to the
dragon of Revelation 12.
dragon has 12 heads correct the Beast of
chapter 13 has seven heads and that of
Revelation 17 has seven heads
this shows conclusively that the dragon
and these two beasts are symbols of the
same power
under different heads
for there are not three sets of seven
heads but it is evident that the heads
are successive forms of its power
one of them bearing rule at a time and
then giving place to another
and then he interprets what the last
three represent
the proper period of each seems to be
this
the dragon before the 1260 years that's
Pagan Rome the Beast of chapter 13 the
papacy during the 1260 years
and the Beast of chapter 17 since the
deadly wound and captivity at the close
of that period which is Rome resurrected
to power right after having a period
where it is out of commission
uh also Ellen White has an interesting
statement that is found in signs of the
times February 8 1910 where she wrote
this
under the symbols of the great red
dragon that's Revelation 12 the Pagan
Rome of course a leopard-like beast
that's the beast from the sea in
Revelation 13. an abuse with lamb-like
horns
that's the verse beast from the earth in
Revelation 13. notice she she mentions
three the great red dragon Pagan Rome
the leopard-like Beast papal room and a
beast with lamb-like horns that is the
United States correct the Earthly
governments which would be especially
engaged in trampling upon God's law and
persecuting his people were presented to
John
their war is to be carried until the
close of time the people of God
symbolized by a holy woman and her
children are represented as greatly in
the minority in the last days only a
Remnant still exists John speaks of them
as those that keep the Commandments of
God and have the testimony of Jesus
Christ so very clearly Ellen White
explains that the great red dragon Pagan
Rome the leopard-like Beast which is
papal Rome and the Beast with lamb like
horns the United States are the powers
that at the end are going to mess with
God's law and they are going to
persecute God's people so the seven
heads are persecuting Powers against
God's people and France doesn't fit that
scenario because France did not
persecute God's people France persecuted
the Beast that it gave the deadly wound
to that's the right thing you have said
and explain it very well praise the Lord
for that I believe that is really quite
clear when we present the evidence that
the identity of that eighth is none
other than the resurrection as you
mentioned what the eighth means of that
papacy that Beast or that power that
will be given the authority by the
United States to persecute the Saints so
I think that is a very well covered
answer to praise the Lord for that well
I think that uh once again I want to
reiterate that if you would like the
33-page document that I wrote which um
you know kind of uh puts everything
together it's like pieces of a puzzle
you know you have to find where the the
pieces of the puzzle fit absolutely and
I interpret every single word and phrase
in Revelation chapter 17 if you want a
copy of that you can email Secrets
unsealed and or some TV and I will be
glad to send that to you also get the
copy of the book The Woman and the Beast
in Revelation and I think that it'll be
a great benefit I think you'll be able
to make sense out of this chapter and we
have that book to write to uh to share
with our friends we carry by the way the
book is by Lewis Weir who who lived in
the 40s and 50s and they have been
reprinted we carry many of his books
yesterday I went to DARE in our
distribution director and asked him
about this book he said no we've never
ordered that book but it is available
and so we are going to order a supply so
people be able to order it from us or if
you want you can order from the
publisher yeah whatever directly okay
thank you Pastor but very important
material please write us if you want
that study by Pastor Bohr about the
Revelation 17 Bears diverse don't forget
to write us and ask for that we'll email
it to you without any charge now let's
go to the next question Pastor board
would you mind uh okay what is that
question well this question is
interesting and comes from us from uh
Wilson maybe the same person it is
actually yes and he is interested in
finding out about a specific uh
a verse in the Bible and it says the
question is this
Deuteronomy 1 39 tells us that the
children or little ones which had no
knowledge between good and evil enter
into the promised land with Caleb and
Joshua does this mean that at the second
coming of Jesus all the little children
who died before they had any knowledge
of good or evil will resurrected for
example all the babies that died during
delivery or even babies that were
avoided by their mothers while they're
still in the womb thank you so much for
the ministry and for us in the question
so
this question is in regards to a verse
in the Bible and maybe we should read
that verse just to kind of you know see
what it says and it's really in relation
to the fact or the question is will
children
babies
be in heaven that did not know the
knowledge of Good and Evil and will that
mean that they are actually into
promised land or they will be in heaven
as well so let's let's see that
and
I don't possibly have that verse
Deuteronomy 1 39.
I am getting there
you have to do it around me 139 yes
well okay moreover your little ones and
your children
who you say will be victims who today
have no knowledge of Good and Evil they
shall go in there to them I will give it
and they shall possess it all right so
is that a verse indicating that in
heaven children can go or babies will go
you know that didn't have no knowledge
of Good and Evil what are your thoughts
I have uh some quotes from Spirit
prophecy in regards to that but
what is what is your initial impression
about this question I don't think we
have a definitive answer in the Bible
um I we do have some hints from the
spirit of Prophecy which probably you
have some of those quotations there
um you know the main point is this
that anything that God does we will
agree that it was right correct uh we're
not going to say well Lord you know that
baby who was born isn't here why isn't
he here you know that's the reason for
the investigative judgment absolutely so
we can see every single case and know
that God acted properly in every single
case I think it'd be a good idea you
might have some of the quotations that I
do for you to read some of those
quotations yes pastor and this that I I
think you really hit the nail in the
head in the sense that we don't know
have a definite answer and it's perfect
actually tells us that and I'll read
that quote at the end uh because we
don't know exactly like you said the
judgment is done by the Lord and He will
do the right thing nevertheless there
are some indications that can give
certain Assurance to parents that have
been faithful you know it speaks of of
these
um uh in this is found in Child Guidance
page 565 566 and it says the following
says you inquire in regard to your
little one being saved Christ's words
are your answer
suffer little children to come unto me
and forbid them not for of such is the
kingdom of God remember the prophecy
thus said the Lord I've always was heard
in Rama lamentation I'm better weeping
Rachel weeping for her children refused
to be comforted thus the Lord refrain
thy voice from weeping and thy eyes from
tears for thy Works shall be rewarded
said the Lord and they shall come again
from the land of the enemy and there is
hope in thy end said the Lord that thy
children shall come again to thy own
border that promise is yours you may be
comforted and trust in the Lord the Lord
has often instructed me that many little
ones are to be laid away before the time
of trouble we shall see our children
again we shall need them and know them
in the Heavenly courts so here is one
quote that she's basically saying you
know have faith God will resurrect those
children and then another quote that she
talks about
uh in regards to the parents being the
ones that sort of uh
I guess if they're they are just and
they have been righteous They will
receive the children it says I know that
some question whether the little
children of even believe in parents
should be saved because I have not had
nothing they have not had a test of
character and almost be tested under
character determined by the trial the
question is ask how can little children
have this test and trial I answer that
the faith or the believing parents cover
the children
and when God sent us when God sent his
judgments upon the firstborns of the
Egyptians Christ blessed children
brought to him by the faithful mothers
he will do this now if mothers will do
their duty to their children and teach
their children and educate them in
obedience and submission they will bear
the test and will be obedient to the
will of God for parents stand in the
place of God to their children so here
again is affirming the concept that if
you have a child and you are being
faithful as a parent and you teach them
if they are taken away from you the Lord
will return them to you now the last
quote I would say is in regards to these
other aspects of
you know not knowing exactly what
happens to the other children you know
the ones that are from non-believers and
that kind of thing she says the
following in selected messages
chapter I mean volume 3 verse uh page
sorry 3-15 it says there
I said to brother Myerson whether all
the children of unbelieving parents will
be saved we cannot tell because God has
not made known his purpose in regards to
his mother and we had better leave it
where God has left it and dwell upon
subjects made plain in his word amen so
I think that sums up Pastor you know the
these as you mentioned in this idea that
kids uh that are born to unrighteous
parents or that are you know aborted or
die in the womb we don't know that
there's no evidence we don't have an
assurance I believe that it's important
we keep that in mind there's another
quotation I'll read it quickly in the
book Heaven page 45 as the little
infants come forth Immortal from their
Dusty beds they immediately Wing their
way to their mother's arms they meet
again never more to part but many of the
little ones who have no mother have no
mother there we listen in vain for the
rapturous song of Triumph from the
mother the Angels received the
motherless infants and conduct them to
the tree of life so there's going to be
some some infants not children but
infants who are going to be there even
though their mother is not there well
time is just about up
yes indeed so we thank you for really
joining us and we pray that you will be
blessed hope to see you next time may
God bless you
[Music]